what is the difference between
percentage and percentile in school
we've seen percentage while in some
comparative exams it's percentile what's
the difference let us take a simple
example
say there are 50 students in your class
and your marks are 480 out of 750 what's
your percentage here percentage would be
480 divided by 750 multiplied by 100
which is 64 percent
this 64 doesn't help you in comparing
yourself with other students then how
does percentile help and how do we
calculate it
suppose your rank in the class is ninth
we have a very simple formula to
calculate the percentile the numerator
will have the number of students who
scored lesser marks than you did and the
denominator will have the total number
of students
multiply this by 100 so 41 divided by 50
multiplied by 100 is 82 so the answer is
82 percentile
as your rank 9th in the class your
percentile is 82. this means 82 of the
students have scored lesser marks than
you did so in your class if there are
100 students and your rank is 21 then
what is your percentile let us know in
the comment section below